right y'all laughs flashpoint number 10
advance is what is going on sir oh you
know the world of destiny continues to
keep going on dead game hashtag hashtag
game I mean but we'll have a lot of
things to say we got the go fast update
came out patch one point one point for
this week Bungie you've got a couple
Twitter things articles we got a lot of
stuff to talk about so heads up for you
guys if you're tuned in for this one
lots of audio coming your way so if you
do want to minimize this listen to the
background download on your phone take
it on a run we're going to be talking
for a bit this is gonna be straight-up
long point today no flash point point
baby no it let's get to it man let's get
to we got a lot to talk about
so we'll just jump into the patch notes
guys we're not gonna try and read these
verbatim but we are gonna hit most
things that we feel need discussion so
it does there's a lot to hear to cover
so we're gonna go through those and kind
of the most efficiently way we can
so to start strikes got some changes and
we're just gonna jump straight into it
this is on the top of the list so we're
going in Oh nightfall strike unique
rewards ah I appreciate you chuckles
what why the chuckles sir what causes
yeah well what is it you know I'd like
you to put it into words or our
listeners out there and viewers people
you know listen I don't know if you guys
have been under a rock as far as the
this whole narrative with the strikes
epic Awards obviously is something
that's been missing from d1 I mean from
d2 that wasn't d1 we had great stuff
like you know I crashed my lock you know
all type of things that we can go into
from d1 that will usually unique is
specific to the actual boss in the
encounter that you face at the end of
the strike so it's come to our attention
a couple of these rewards that have been
leaked and needless to say these are
very underwhelming was a sniper it
literally had the same body type of
almost a standard hockey oz sniper it
had you know two perks that was
switchable at the end what were very
underwhelmed
even you know just we talked about this
before my last flash my even just from a
aesthetic standpoint it just looks plain
yeah I mean the one for this week is
pretty lackluster there's the way I
would describe it and unfortunately it's
like we had our hopes raised just a bit
not too much but when they said hey
we're gonna push him back another month
there you go I'll let you go we're gonna
let you know our artists spend some time
work on making them better and then we
turn around and I honestly didn't want
to look I didn't want to look in like
cheek cuz I wasn't gonna know but then I
was literally in a fireteam with
somebody who got one on console and I
looked at it now it's just kind of like
I just didn't have any words I was just
I was hoping for more mm-hmm I mean so
it's the pyrimidines the strike this
week if you guys aren't aware and when
you go through obviously it's the boss I
think it's Dracula if I remember right
yes and he has this little like slap
rifle so I mean in my opinion you could
have done it two ways if you want to
sniper rifle out there and especially as
you boo see snipers that's cool
but give me one that still looks like
his gun
give me one that has a little more of a
feel to rip it off of his arm and let's
hold it now it would have been even
cooler since they actually have them in
the game
give me a what they just buff stuff like
tarantula mm-hmm give me the linear
pulse rifle and that would have
literally been like taking his arm off
and walking around with it that would
have felt cooler I think that's what a
strike specific reward is supposed to be
you you want that feeling that what you
are earning is as a result of the spoils
of war the same thing with the raid when
we beat those bosses the gear is
reflective the weapons are reflective
there is nervous all this stuff looks
like Generic Reese kids and that don't
even get me started with they're given I
shot like ghosts and sparrows that also
look similar to like standard ghosts
instead with minor things not that they
didn't do anything but here's my big
brownie bounces we gave them a pass for
saying hey we're gonna push this thing
back
right because you know we want our
design artist to take time and when we
gonna cook up some really nice for you
god I'm like dude this is what we waited
for no not a good luck unfortunately
that is true so I mean I looked at a
couple of the others but it's they have
a couple cosmetic I say cosmetics from
pretty much anything that doesn't affect
gameplay so not armor weapons ghosts is
in there can give you some perks but
you've got sparrows you've got a ship
you've got trying to think I feel like
I'm missing one category but you've got
all those medics yeah it's like go
Sparrow and then you know a couple of
weapons here and there but um yeah
pretty pretty limited and you know oh no
armor yeah no armor no nothing like that
to me is a big problem too yeah yeah I
still remember my a warlock falling
saber helmet you did me again I looked
at dark blade helmet off the top for the
Titan yeah one of my favorites for looks
just you look so different than anything
else cuz I mean you look like a hive
skull is sitting on your head they walk
around and if that was something that
walked around the tower like and you got
that one the first week and it was a
high of one and you have like a high of
skull sitting on your head
what okay so takes a bethune song for
example and say it'd be cool see if they
had nightfall strike rewards' make them
as rare as they are I hear they're hard
to get like six or nine strikes people
have done with no success so I mean
rarity is good right but take late
Sabbath rune song for example you want a
cool warlock bond put literally Sabbath
rune on your arm yes let's go what I
mean stuff like that but do like a piece
of armor and this is where I don't know
again I wonder if on something like this
there's one artist who had to design all
this because I wonder if every other
person in the world of Bungie he isn't
working on other stuff showing I wonder
what the scale of the live team is right
now right with the vast desire for large
system changes that are needed right now
we'll cover that stuff later but
I'm kind of wondering if they're just
limited on people and again at that
point if it's like if one dude has to
sit there and render and fix and all
this stuff like right those are just get
like months in like a year before gas
comes out okay you're just going hey
we're gonna make this in a month the
dudes like uh I'm gonna do it I can like
wish me luck and again like dude Bungie
I know they're they don't have a
thousand people sitting on the thumbs
there's no way so I know they're working
on something again all of us are like we
just you know but if you're gonna hope
got a follow through
that's just all we want to hope for so
no I hear you man I just I still
struggle in this case to give them a
pass just on the simple fact that like I
said we waited that extra time that they
need because this was supposed to come
crier to the last in the last update
this was supposed to be part of it and
again you know all I'm saying is look
I'm not trying to disrespect any artists
or disrespect you know the work that is
involved with this kind of stuff as well
as the fact like you you making a good
point I don't know the level of staffing
it might just be the lot team all I'm
saying right is can I get a completely
different design that's all I'm saying
the base look of a gun looking exactly
the same as everything else my - one or
two minor things like that's what I saw
on a lot of these strike exclusive
awards and to be honest he just really
desensitizes you to make you even want
to do it you look at it like I'm gonna
grind for that I mean that's an elbow a
night fault if I get it I get it but
it's not even and then I guess the thing
that added just a little cherry on top
for me there's the fact that the sniper
that dropped out of a nightfall strike
net perks that gave you more benefit in
PvP yeah at least at the very minimum
should have given us maybe a couple of
new perks that are just unique to those
rewards right see you know oh this is
new I've never seen this before your
enemy and it helps you maybe do
something in that's right or toward
certain enemy types or something
something they gotta do better down if
you're dropping it in PvP and you want
it to be like hey you want it to be a
boss melting sniper okay so when your
aim down sights
if you hit a crit
you know maybe you every two curts or
something you get a bullet back and it's
like I mean that's literally black
spindle so I mean that's kind of
cheating but no one would complain if
they brought something like that back in
and it was hard to get give you a reason
to go crying for it
so X you know continue keel over long
baby that was a big topic though we knew
it just because it was one we've been
waiting on and wanted to see what they
were so I didn't peek at the videos
people dug into the database and when
it's I think at least half cosmetics
there's three weapons there's a hand
cannon
there's the auto rifle and the sniper
rifle I think those are the three though
yes so if you have three weapons and the
rest of cosmetics like you maybe if this
is all you get now have that person keep
working and adding more in there right
yeah
like make it a bigger pool if you don't
get the weapon maybe there's a piece of
armor later so I could they could add
more in time I just don't know again if
that's a priority for them there's I
really do strike repetition reduction
that's pretty straightforward challenge
card you can make the strike feat
nightfall a little bit harder and then
they fixed a few issues with the night
falls
other than that exotic repetition
reduction as we said it's only from
engrams not from milestones so if you're
still getting duplicates like your fifth
pair of a on Swift's Hill your pain and
me and everybody else so they fix a
couple of issues but let's jump in to
these sand box Jews the big one yeah all
right guys so weapons as we saw
previously a lot of them were giving a
PvE boost and from what I've gathered
from a lot of people myself included PvE
weapons are feeling a little better
you're feeling a little more powerful
just across the board and they made some
substantial boosts in PvE too a couple
of the power weapons trying to bring
them up in line but we'll kind of get to
the whole weapon slot discussion and
stuff later but a lot of these things
seem great for PvE now the feel in PvP
on the other side what are I'm gonna let
you dabble in that one first because you
literally played it this morning yeah
man I've been I've been going hard I
mean and let me get full disclosure on
very I'm gonna say overall I'm I'm okay
with a lot of stuff in the update is
everything perfect no um as you know I'm
a Medigap
so this update was something I was very
excited to just dig deep break
everything down you know and um it's one
of those things that this is where
frequency and updates really to me we
energize the base because it was cool to
see people in the crucible trying
different things out seeing what was
going on you know I mean and I know
we're gonna right now with Japanese up
and all that stuff is on the screen I
will say pulses are back this is my
short-term analysis pulses are back they
definitely feel valuable ideal Oh have
it on PC yet I looked I had it on
consoles like Oh surely I've been on PC
I was like oh crap you can't get that
thing maybe he'll sell it today who
knows you know what you gotta get it
it's so you got that like posters are
back and that's good because it's a
skill weapon it rewards the headshots
it's good to see it back in its glory
shout out to my time war inspired baby
whoa I was wrecking face what time was
fired baby dust that off there's a
couple of little gems in there I've been
touching on last Perdition felt nice
um swift ride so try to think of some
noteworthy ones that are really just you
know touched out
um surprisingly I was it was it I
believe Lincoln green nightshade those
ones not as much nightshade for a second
I was like I think you forgot this one
yeah it's not I don't got that feel you
never saying but um and I got a tryout
there's only a few of the heavy the high
impact posts architect there's one
called three grieves I didn't get a
chance to really put it through its
paces yet but I will say in PvE the
heavies feel good too the heavy pulses
feel good yeah and um especially I got
one with a nice but if you got one with
like a rampage or you got one you know
kill clip and all that stuff that really
feels nice you know I'm saying so shout
out today I also want a shout out
um dragonfly telling you right now
audience Dustoff them guns that got
dragonfly um what I like is I'm not
gonna say it's Firefly level d1 but they
made a significant jump with the
animation on the explosion so that you
as long as you get the crit you will
damage or potentially kill ads in
grouped up together it's really fun so
dust off all your Dragonfly ones and for
those who are worried about the nerf
with um yeah it's not it's still good
it's not good
all right it's still good so that's what
I got right now on there's still
archetypes dummy shotguns felt good I
just do my quick synapses you know stuff
um Scott Scout rifles high-impact
disappointed I thought it was gonna hit
more like a truck I'm up in you up
Annunciation olds d1 you call it what
casitas I call a cocky just because I'm
sure it was like right in the middle and
that was the slower harder hitting right
like they still don't hit hard enough in
my opinion you know I mean they're a
little better but not significantly so I
still don't can't you say they're viable
as well as like high impact hand cannon
and stuff like that you know
um hand cannons okay for the most part
still nothing crazy you know I felt they
were all you know this solid and last
button oh lady a fusion fusion life and
salute salute yeah man dusted off
tarantula man beast oh man like they're
very viable in PvE even in my pain
warning sniper and the ammo you get you
like disgusting you know I'm saying so
that's that and I was hoping for a
little bit more with grenade launchers
unfortunately we did that one going in
though I mean they were literally just
boosting blast radius
yeah you're right you'd have known I
thought maybe that might be substantial
shout out to a few to people that killed
we would play at a game and crucible you
know those dudes I was a little upset
you know they think must be really
skilled and I guess it's one perk the
one that like detonates close yeah play
the game has that perk so I guess that
one but even so like you said he bounces
it should be much that
should be a one-shot Unitas and did it
like did the grenade one-shot you or is
it always take usually sometimes I was
getting one shot but I guess he this
guy's just so skilled at placement it's
not like a what's the joint arm with the
colony yeah well you can kind of to tap
walk away and it's none of that like you
have to eat that one person here so that
right there and the last thing Oh
shout-out to CJ Gibson from fire team
chat um I was watching a stream when
when the update went alive he actually
got me using a wizened rebuked fusion
rifle Oh
ujin's feel nice they'll still take a
lot of skill but that's it so that's my
overall assessment on the weapon types
for the most part some some some
adjustments in PvP have gone up you know
some things still haven't really I'm not
a cyber guy so I can't give you that
critique unfortunately I didn't really
get a chance to go in there but oh and
last last but not least um auto rifles I
do feel a Nerf difference with the with
the very popular ones like lets you know
Uriel's yeah um positive outlook my bit
was my baby um those are the two big
ones I'm thinking of true but my
personal was its iron banner um oh yeah
like for path feels weaker and you know
what I'm not mad at it because the end
at the end of the day that was the
dominant meta prior yeah and I'm liking
pulse is beating them out as a scale
weapon that's just me but I always feel
the skill should be rewarded to land the
headshots and stuff like that so I don't
have a problem with that but that's just
my assessment of everything so far you
hit a lot of high notes and again I'm
not gonna read these patch notes
word-for-word yeah that's what we're
here for
go to Bungie I'll try and link them in
the description um you know our videos
and stuff like that a couple that you
didn't hit that I've heard some some
pretty good things on submachine guns
and sidearms especially in PvE now seal
reasonable especially sidearms they get
a little boost in inventory so more ammo
to be stored for both of them
PvE damage boost on both of them just
guns that typically if you were gonna
run around and probably get a little
closer to stuff
I'm gonna watch dados video and he said
I was running around with like a
submachine gun from most of like the
rating
and during flight yes I will not do that
before cuz they felt just a little too
much like peashooters and now they've
got they mo to go with the speed and you
can kind of pair it nicely so I mean
these are all steps on the right
direction for having just general
gameplay feel good [ __ ] shout out
too long yeah this up because actually
there was a few that I felt were viable
there's a new Marquis one-world
dispensation I believe something like
that the one the ones with grave-robber
beast because when you run up you get a
slap and now you get more of an increase
on the reserved ammo yeah so I love the
900 classes those are good on shout out
was the other one heroes burdens beasts
in PvP I'm giving away secrets never oh
no in the last one if you're got the
cursor Osiris dfdl see I believe it's
arm soul pariah fat one
it sits in the energy slot beast beast
beast bees bees it has grave-robber as
well
so yes the stop subs are really nice
right now gotta get gotta give me credit
map correct well yeah I mean Ferger nade
launchers you're talking about increased
blast radius drum fed half a meter one
shot one meter that's it yeah so like if
they're as tragic as they are I mean
they needed I think they needed more of
a wheat rework than blast writers I'll
try a couple of them out that I've got
but I don't see it being a major by any
means I agree but that covers most of
them guys again you can read them most
them did get so I mean for example I
know Shadow the linear fusion rifles in
PvE it's a 50% damage bonus that's huge
that's shotguns 35% damage bonus to
increased inventory here's a melting
yellow boss not to touch me Lily's a
melting yellow Basra yeah so I mean
Hawthorne's just dump that ammo and
it'll be tearing stuff up
so it still makes more things viable
especially if you have a mix of play
styles if you got to play conservative
you go solo like I do you kind of are
limited on options I'm probably not
gonna go try and shotgun a boss and be
like really Jenkins or something but you
know you know I think a lot of is gut
steps in the right direction yes sir so
we had a few perks that got changed
scaled up for PvE damage high impact
reserves kill clip rampage
you mentioned dragon fly so it's damaged
for example went from 50 to 65 so the
30% boost and plus 30% additional damage
against combatants I guess that means in
PvP so they updated the graphics on that
one explosive rounds so this is the one
where they decrease the explosive our
end damage multiplier by 15% would
increase PvE damage for the base weapons
so it should hit about the same yeah if
it still felt strong and the name was
mean I feel strong man yeah and I think
nameless will probably not get affected
because its base is probably gonna get
boosted and this is more like better
Devils is probably gonna feel a little
more in line as it should not wear those
long-distance better double shots still
hit route of a range that I think a hand
cannon should be effective I love the
gun and it was great when I was using it
but sitting there using a hand cannon
it's hitting harder than a scout at
range I'm like something's wrong with
that so I'm alright with that in the
grand scheme making things be logical oh
now we've got abilities so many things
changed we know the big one super
generation rate was down from 640 to 5
minutes so we knew that 25% change
happened mm-hm
the output of every increment in the
mobility staff from 2 to 10 has been
increased allowing force if it's a
significant boost in player speed hold
that thought guys there's a caveat there
they had made some changes there for
basically breaking aim-assist and
tracking and things like that so we've
talked about those before increase the
movement speed of melee super so fist of
havoc sandal shield Ark staff which from
what I've seen those are actually pretty
fun to use those movement supers where
you're running around those are actually
pretty cool I've got a little bit faster
your you know cranked up so those are
pretty cool but let's come
back to this mobility step for a second
before I express opinions um do you have
some opinions of your own I think we're
pretty much on the same page which is
but you know we do um it's disappointing
I mean let shout out to my man fall our
place yeah let's just get to it you know
you put the video out basically breaking
it down and this is again something that
I thought you know remember we talked
about this at nauseam you know mobility
doesn't really matter it was just
straight speed and we thought for sure
when they were talking about it that you
know they were gonna rework this stuff
you know make mobility and then you hear
to go fast thing and you know for the
most part you know when it comes to you
know Titan skating and warlock bursts
gliding salute feel faster I'm flying
around the map love it have to give them
credit right I have never felt as agile
with a warlock but again this is because
of my jump that's like that specific I
mean you can go smell splat into a wall
with the warlock because of that what is
that the glide stepper I'm trying to
remember the name I'm saying it wrong so
yeah you come on what to eat I was like
first glide first thought yeah that's
the word I was looking for sorry yeah
with that one I mean they start that
thing going and they're literally going
faster than a sparrow can go like
they're flying across the map which is
awesome mm-hmm but then yeah when we
talk about a normal step what do you so
I mean when you think about a mobility
step sorry I cut you off and it's not
their mobility it's like how what do you
what do you think of a mobility
I think of four basic run speed and
sprint speed almost everywhere you go
you click the little button and you go
sprint because that's what everybody
uses mm-hm and that still has not been
changed as sorry I cut you off so back
to your follow-up video that's pretty
much finishing up I mean it was just
disappointing to find out that again
this is really you know straight speed
and that's about it and this is
disappointing you know at the at the end
of the day I don't know if it's a you
know a dev issue where they just can't
make that change but um it's just really
disappointing that
the name of your update is go fast why
are we not sprinting vast let's just
call it what it is so yeah you know I'm
again because of the other things that
they've done I don't feel it as bad but
it should have been there and that's
concerning so I'm gonna let you take it
man no I mean you covered most of that's
what I was trying to get it out there in
a more uh you know savvy explanation but
I mean general that was kind of what we
were hoping for as we talked about
previously if I'm gonna go mobile
mobility ten and I'm gonna give up some
other stats to get there
I should be able to outrun you I should
be able to get to a point quicker not
just be like hey if we walk next to each
other and I look over I'm gonna I'll
walk you but if we start sprinting we're
gonna basically have the same 40 times
so and it's just kind of one of those
I'm and that's why I wonder about the
whole armor stats question mark there's
a lot of stuff in there but mobility as
you're saying if you're gonna go fast
and you have a sprint that doesn't
change then 90% of your movement in the
game is done that way and it doesn't
change I think that's a missed
opportunity I guess or one of those
things again where it's a question mark
to be like I don't know how things work
and I guess this is one I was texting
you last night as we were sitting there
going over the stuff I couldn't pass out
soon enough but what I would like
again if like a lot of us are like hey
mobility in my mind I think of movement
I was think of sprinting I think of how
I move in general all the time and
shout-out to Zack and my twitch chat
he's saying it's like Bungie to find
some mobility differently then tell me
how you define it if I mouse over a
little tool tip that pops up there
everywhere else put just a couple on
those stats and be like hey this is what
this does yes do that they didn't
definitely do it yeah here one two three
four and five lightning if you have ten
stat points for resilience and be like
hey your health is 181 at level zero if
you get up to level 10 its 201 let us
see that just so we know I mean that
would just be one of those things that
would at least take some questions as
opposed to I mean you know fallout would
have one less video to do but I
for us if like mobility is literally and
from what he's tested pretty much
confirms it's strafe speed in your
initial jump height if that's what
mobility is supposed to affect just tell
us so I don't ever get my hopes up if it
will never change then at least let me
know so yeah absolutely
a man who preaching all right guys so
different classes got some boosts
warlock got a lot of fun
so we can start there if you guys
haven't seen the videos out there for a
warlock burst gliding literally across a
DZ and then going chris flat like
they're going too fast in the hit lin
front of a car window like a bug same
idea basically they get going too quick
they can't stop and they're done when
it's really cool like dawn blade can
move across maps that can throw an extra
sword yeah it's pretty fun to watch so I
mean I've seen some warlocks tearing
stuff up I like they it needed a buff I
didn't see dawn blade used very often so
it was nice to see it running around a
little more and even in PvE just in
videos and stuff I've seen pop-up I've
seen it more frequently used because you
can get that extra throw you're up there
you feel they're feeling a little more
godly and that's a little more girly
however I did the caveat um you know
unfortunately because the wait d2 is is
set up with the skill trees it's like
you know you have to pick that one where
the actual you know normally super you
know sword strikes actually track
because the other one doesn't
which is very hard to really nail those
this thing is the main perk of that top
tree is supposed to be about being in
the air so you want to throw that you
know um though your wings a sacred dawn
on and the main one of the one of the
hot it works in PvE which is if I'm in
the air and I get killed I literally
like boost up my arm grenade and melee
energy ridiculous right so I think it's
constant synergy of getting you know
grenade and whatever and um class
million stuff the problem is they still
nerfed in in air accuracy to the ground
yeah so it's still no benefit now that
I'm moving fast I'm feeling good but I'm
shooting him like why am I not hitting
my target
it does not accurate it going so fast
you can't name they really really need
to adjust that like that hat that it
kills that top tree that top tree is
supposed to be about being in the air
getting abilities supposed to be synergy
with it and um yeah because of that
thing for when everybody still has this
thing I heard they are gonna address it
I didn't member seeing someone you know
Bungie say that it's coming but they
have to because you know just gonna be
pigeonholed into one one style of a
normally for the most part I'm solely
for the other two we got Titans
I know on PC and I'm guessing it's by
macros for just very fast key
combination somebody technically has
Titans skated but it's not like back
mm-hmm so you can do a little bit with
that strafe lift also hunters the hunter
arc staff animations I've seen have
gotten really fun to use yes quick
they're fast there you can actually
chase somebody down you're super
god bless your soul if they up that
auction is coming for ya if they're
coming for you you're not gonna outrun
them anymore which is honestly good if
you're doing acrobatic crazy arc staff
stuff you should be covering more ground
and you should be able to catch them so
yeah I mean our staff like have some fun
guys go go wreck some people go into it
some PvE jump into a group of guys and
just destroy them all have some fun it's
gonna be a good time yeah also a
reminder real quick mods that effect
regenerates for like grenades melee
stuff like that they have had their
output increased yes they camp at 3 mods
but it's again it's a 50% regen rate if
you notice altogether which is net which
is substantial
yep kudos to that oh that's thing like
that alright so next we come to crucible
weekly featured playlist has been
initiated so the first one starts with a
rumble before we get too much farther
down I'm just gonna say it Rumble is
insanity it is absolute insanity now
some of it for better because there are
times when you're like you know two
teams sticking together peak in corners
you're not getting that many kills
it's insanity all the time if you put
your controller down for like if you
sneeze you're probably gonna die
thanks you gotta be focused in Rumble so
but in turn as most of many people
guessed already and it was like that
just in community podcast they were
saying there's they're wondering was
like these maps are not the biggest in
the first place right for 4v4 footfalls
is law so spawn locations are apparently
a difficult thing because if you've
watched any videos in tested his where
he was just camping to spawn points
there's only so many and people are
spawning on you all the time I can be
standing here and a doodle spawn right
next to me right next to you and he's
got an over shield yes you're in trouble
so it's your I mean you to get a kill
streak of more than one in Rumble right
now shout out to him test as well
apparently if you can hold a point
between a couple spawns and find one and
then pop that devourer and get some mmm
okay so that's what he was playing with
a little bit he says it's you know it's
kind of can occur me to do but it was
working that's kind of the point to
where people are saying ate too many
yeah I mean listen and I'm torn because
I went 8 was announced I'm like man I
like that I'm all about hot play account
I'm all about not separating from my
friend you know haven't you know just
haven't even though you can't bring 8
technically together inside a rumble but
you know just I do like I break out and
it's just like you said it's the
combination of one bad spawns you know
it should into these maps really aren't
designed for this so if they're gonna do
this they literally almost have to
create a you know Rumble specific Maps
yeah and certain Maps just can't fall in
the rotation because it's just it's too
chaotic I was playing a couple matches
you know before we did the podcast and
it's just like well I mean literally
like you spoiling this someone in your
face already it's like I'm doing more
cleanup duty waiting for people to fight
as opposed to I mean you get into a
one-on-one getting your head pinched by
two other people it's really crazy and
it it sucks because I love Rumble you
know me and I really
yeah I want this thing to succeed and I
was just like damn can they watch this
one so part of me is like you know they
got ambitious for like let's give them
eight players let's go all out yeah I
like that I like to throw it I like the
concept but it just doesn't fit with the
with the spawns and it doesn't fit with
these maps so you have to if you're
gonna if you're gonna double down on
eight which I'm fine like I said I'm in
the minority I'm one of the few that
still doesn't I still like the fact that
they attend today but you just can't
have these current maps you know yeah
you need like something like anomaly or
asylum yes make them about 50% bigger
because yes 8p I mean six people knows
you could spawn have a second check your
ATAR or figure out where your
engagements are gonna come from now
sometimes you might get pinched from you
know somebody jumping across map but
it's not literally gonna be spawn I
shoot you a dude's coming up behind me a
guy's jumping over a cliff you just had
four deaths in the same spot in light of
tentacles it's ridiculous yeah there
little preview video if you watch the
Bungie videos like the ones on this week
at Bungie if you watch the little blip
they talk about Rumble like three kills
happen within three seconds since like
that's too fast too fast it's way too
fast we want time to kill whole
different topic later took it too far
like four Rumble it's just a little too
chaotic for the fun because it really
it's a really good mole that just any
have to they have to get that resolved I
was like I've always liked it for either
jumping and just to work on my
one-on-one yes my skill call my skills
I'm gonna go one-on-one with somebody
how am I ever gonna get better at the
shooting I mean something no I mean it's
fine but there's those points where it's
like for me to match up with somebody
and let me see how I can work on those
headshots be a little more accurate with
the straight shot and tagging and if I
can't focus on one shot then two more
coming from either side of my head I'm
done before I can practice
absolutely so you really don't get a
good gauge of what's actually effective
yep it's just so chaotic so next week
will be mayhem we'll cover it later but
they do have a Bungie bounty coming back
so you're gonna be going after Cosmo and
Dillon and a couple other people in
there so I may jump in and see if I can
get there it's on PC but mayhem
just happy it's coming back yeah also I
wish some of these just stayed all the
time yeah that's true too we would like
you to stay you know take out Rumble
mayhem and then iron banner will be the
other rotation so that's the order it
seems to be going in Rumble mayhem iron
banner good to see ya but we've got 12
people on a map where we feel 8 is
almost already too much for from Rumble
yeah I guess maybe it's different
because it steams because you know yeah
I think you know hopefully just maybe
splitting up into like three and three
you might be Greco but I was like if
somebody runs as a full team of six and
you're split man you're gonna like just
driven over crucible repetition
reduction and quitter penalties just
good positive quality life things there
iron banner so we know what 6v6 time
limit will be 12 minutes score limit is
125 respawn time is seven seconds now
this they changed hmm instead of control
iron banner all zones start as neutral
so instead of having a and everybody
just be lining for me everybody has to
have at least somebody stand in that
four zone even even if it's just one
person to efficiently pick that first
one up which probably would be smart or
ending go run for B or C or whatever but
additional guardians in the zone
increased the capture speed as well I
always like this love that I'm in d1
that was good because then you'd have
those points where people are trying to
get one and you could have those super
slim kill three or four people there's
no benefit to everybody being there
before so towards the objective yeah it
just does yeah you play the objective
and it matters emperor's respite has
been removed and I don't know why do you
I just think the way the spawns are set
up they they looked at it and it's just
like I'm so balanced yeah it's like you
can really kind of done I've played that
map a lot in them you can dominate kids
but yeah with the way things especially
I believe that the one in the center
dome and the one outside and it's just
you can just wreck
up and hold that fort down so I think
that that's what it is yeah they could
move like be a little farther outside to
the right oh yeah that's gonna drop off
yes then take a and put it farther and
that might spread it a little farther
you can't almost like line-of-sight to
points because the exact specs yeah uh
power ammo recurring side create so
recurring side crate respawn times from
90 seconds to 45 initial side create
respawn times from 90 down to 30 mm-hmm
so this amongst other things our ammo is
gonna be coming quick yeah and I got a
comment on it and I mean well this is
this is just for iron banner right well
this is across the board but right now
just showing this gotta see there see
our rocks
that'll be one of the things because I
thought I was worried about I'll be
honest I was worried about all the power
and mode changes you know for current
PvP number I told you I was cringing I
know he bothers I don't know getting a
little to power ammo heavy but to be
honest I don't mind it because in the
prior state there were times where's
like damn I didn't I felt like I wasn't
getting anything you know and then you
know you have that those greedy
teammates who just you know
excuse my language c-block you know
you're like hold on let me tighten
charge the other way so I can pick up
power and it's like feel and it never
felt that way and do you want to be like
hey if it like through you're defending
it one will pop it cuz we're close by
then we all turn around and pick it up
now it's like who's gonna like box out
so you can take that yeah a little
basketball boom just to get it so it's
like you know now because exactly so
it's like because of the frequency now
it's like you know everybody come rock
so it's like you're gonna get your shot
you know you get a shot to show off
power and actually I don't mind it so
far yeah so then they've got
quick play just to match link with its
extended I guess I don't know if that
was a big one or not but now they're
longer so sure all modes they said
increased assist and kill credit time
from two seconds to two and a half no I
don't thats on your super that's kind of
vague yes I know what the kill credit
time is I'm thinking at least the next
line where it's increased super energy
granted from player kills for both kills
and assists well I think those mean the
same thing otherwise I'm not entirely
sure what that first line is talking
about yeah me just killed credit timing
I don't know I just trying to the credit
flow for team shouting and style I don't
know I mean that the second one though I
like I like yes absolutely the second is
that's whose reward skill you know if
the guys getting kills he should be and
also what was great about that is that
one of our main beasts was that everyone
gets to present the same time so if one
person is wrecking face in the crucible
he's getting that super energy you know
I mean faster and you can get is who you
should reward that and I like that I
like when supers are popped at different
times not everyone's timer goes at the
same time there's like yay mayhem for
one time you know yeah it's like and
then back to team shot exactly but yeah
power ml is gonna be more frequent now
they have the bricks dropping which you
have to actually run over it it takes an
order a second interaction to pick it up
you can't just like get drive-thru
supremacy crest and situation if you do
manage to drop somebody and you know
some of its chaotic like if it drops you
give a chance to pick it up and use it
so it's kind of nice quick play you know
all match links extended you know the
power create all that stuff control the
same thing just a lot of overall patch
notes that we'd kind of discuss before
the tracker has turned off and trials of
the nine how was competitive I know you
were jumping in that a little bit this
morning I haven't gotten my sting okay
um again showered the CJ Gibson anakata
cheap check who they would at first I
was kind of watched him do it before I
can actually get a chance to play myself
and yeah I think I pretty much won the
same feel as them which is I like it
right
like it I like not knowing where stuff
is that you have this constant fear
you're looking over your back you're
looking over your shoulder
however the problem that I you realize
is that because like there's no radar at
all you don't even know where your
teammates are and that feels weird
i'ma be honest like you you wanna again
you want to still know where they're at
now grant it when you're playing if
someone's in line of sight you'll see
obviously their arm gamertag or whatever
right but the minute they go off like
you don't know where they are so it it's
weird like part of me is like maybe like
I said you if they don't the radar is
this like maybe the actual circle that
shows the radar should stay as a 10
background template and just the radar
indicators to stay off right because not
know where your team feels weird like
that's my only thing I don't know
exactly
it's hardcore I mean maybe the hard call
and encourage guys like well you know
that's how it should be that's really
what it is it may be just an adjustment
period
but um if I'll be honest overall I was
okay with it you know I felt okay what I
felt I can go off on my own sometimes
and get some flanks here's some shots
going down you know I just like I said
just felt a little weird little making
when you don't know where's my guys at
you know I like sometimes you can
smiling you like I don't know where
anybody so that that that's gonna be an
adjustment I wanna I don't want to quit
like I know that if our team shot guys
were going hard at it I don't want to go
super hard on it yet I want the matter
to settle in I want to see trials this
week I'm gonna play Charles this week
and shout the Sinister the crew will
grab a little couple of guys get it
going from the clan and um really put it
through its paces and see how it really
works you know with the Matt I know I'm
kind of curious I think more were you
doing that just randoms this morning for
competitive yeah yeah so I was like I
think if you're chillin a team in a
party chat yes that's a good point so I
think that communication will help like
don't be like okay so I'm gonna go left
you three go this way I'm gonna try and
flank him from behind with some power mo
I was like I like I'm kind of with you
competitive should make people really do
call-outs understand yep shout-out to
Zack and my Chad he's listening in so
you might be a no long haul on this one
so long Boyd this morning but he's like
makes teamwork proper call out super
super important than its true like
working with your team knowing where I'm
going to be like okay I'm gonna flank
out to the left come far behind him
really trying to be right behind him
you guys keep their focus in front you
know if you got three of them you can do
the flanks before honestly I think the
radar was just to give away because yeah
if you had a couple people you kind of
split to where you can see which one
they're running towards there's no
question and you know if somebody was
gonna flank you be like alright I got
somebody coming up on the left so I like
that I mean yeah I like it for the
purist in me about two still feels it's
the right call I think it's just an
adjustment period
that we're gonna have to do because the
cool thing I will say this and I'm
giving away secrets oh but I will tell
you right now you get that power ammo in
trials are competitive now you are fear
cuz they don't they can't see you don't
know where you're at you know I mean no
I'm like I'm I'm fearing like legend to
a curious guys you know say like oh
you're gonna be running with that
grenade launcher in that competitive
right no play of the game my life yeah
my shotty in trials and competitive are
going to be viable there's no doubt
because there's no you that person turns
that corner
that's it you know I'm saying you get
the drop on somebody chase someone hunt
them down that's it so it's gonna make
them viable is gonna make definitely
make them but it's gonna be interesting
to see I cannot wait to touch trials
this weekend put it through its paces
and see how that rocks out should be fun
I mean I'm I'm glad to see and I like at
least they're starting to make some of
the modes more distinct yes so it's not
just like hey just a little different
type of modes over here number two it's
really making every point competitive is
its own thing I mean this is gonna put
you into basically Inferno mode like in
d1 so
love it love the distinction good point
we've got power mo crates so just a
whole bunch of different mm variation mo
changes most of them except Rockets went
up yeah so in general most are pretty
good ward cliff coil still stays at one
all of them pretty good legend of a
curious now has four shots that's like
that thing isn't saying but all in all
that's most of the patch no it's just
crucible power ammo crate just amounts
that were dropping jamming so that is
most the Pat's notes overall I think
it's a it's a step it's another it's
another step in the right direction do I
think it was everything I think you're
go fast update had some pieces that were
missed and be at the sprint speed which
is a big one for me just because I think
that's what mobility should include but
that's not my decision
you've got the nightfall strike specific
rewards for PvE piece that for me we're
like kind of falling flat a picture a
balloon like deflating that's kind of
what I picture listening to just so it's
just there are good things I like the
way the guns feel in PvE trials being
distinct is cool getting some more power
amount Rumble needs a little tweaking
but I'm glad to see its back
so lots of these pieces are good power a
mode dropping off people gets a little
throw back into very early vanilla d1 so
actually getting some options for those
to be around overall I like most of this
stuff at least steps in the right
direction
but I just to me there was some
substantial missteps that I think pulled
away from the overall liking of this
where I'm focused a bit too much on the
things that didn't quite hit for me as
opposed to enjoying the overall like
kind of boost to many things that I
should be taking in so it's kind of a
mixed bag for me some good some bigger
missteps that kind of are taken away
from them for me what about you yeah man
I mean we are the same same boat man so
um it's just one of those things like I
said overall but you know I think these
are steps in the right direction I fail
you know they you know again like we
always say our is just gonna bring
people back no but at the end of the day
to where I look at it is these
the baby stuff these are things you need
to kind of put you in the right
direction for that next expansion
because ultimately people are not the
masses are not coming back just for your
balance update right that's for the hot
core but when you put this and these
type of frequency of balance updates in
conjunction now with new content I think
what the what the game needs obviously
right now is new content new things to
strive for new missions whatever so when
we get that next DLC that next expansion
you know in May and now you've got a
better base game right on top of that
now it feels different now you starting
to get things going and to your point I
think you're right like it's it's it's
one of those things where I was like
damn like this could have rid of really
amazing like bat you know balance update
if if they just nailed Rumble a little
better right did a you know fix grenade
launcher you're a little like just
misstep here mister yeah but again they
got chances to fix that but I think this
is good overall as long as they correct
those things we talked about and have
that in place
come May May is huge that's my opinion
now because people will want to try out
the new content when people see new
content one try it out you know if you
got most of them already paid for it
most people already in on that expansion
one in two combo pack because that's
when the destiny you know love affair
was high right everybody was in it oh
yeah I'm just fine you know the
expansions you know DLCs and stuff like
that so they've got to come with it I
believe on the exotic stuff the reworks
the that you know that the sandbox stuff
with the with the exotics the master
work exotics there guys still some stuff
to do on that development role map that
should be in line for there and they got
a knock it out the park they really have
to do well with this next expansion in
my opinion you know that combination
well now I was like yeah so hey if you
haven't tried it you want to dabble in
it for a day or two see how it is if you
want to play trials this weekend might
be a good time to give you know when a
few more people might be checking it out
like Cognito if you want to go mop the
floor with him since he's got a practice
go ahead and do
so the good baby because that's usually
what I try and do like I mean I jumped
into rumbling I was like right this is
insane I'm not this bad I was just
getting shot all over the place it's
basically if you can stand back and kind
of get yourself between a couple spawns
you have a shot but again there's gonna
be a third or fourth person coming
around the corner so we'll see on that
one but it is always a post Thursday
discussion so blob is live I don't know
why I'm saying words that way
run gene March 29th is know we know one
point for one point one point for came
out yeah obvious what we just talked
about so there's a little developer
commentary from Josh Hamrick I like his
idea behind it though oh if you haven't
watched this little video here that go
fast commentary watch it it's pretty
cool love the day doing stuff like this
by the way that's good I was like I mean
shout-out to division they do one of
those like every other week every other
week they sit down they do their talk
like I don't know if they just don't
have the time or the production schedule
for it but if it was every other week
maybe not as consistently but even if it
was just a little video they recorded
like this these are the type of things
we want to see a real just a real talk I
mean Josh Hamrick was just laying it
down just not he didn't sound like he
was talking off script he was just like
kind of speaking from the heart for most
of it
so it was pretty cool to hear I
appreciated that one big time
this March update this is the one I was
gonna say if you have not watched this
video I've even seen one advertised a
couple places watch it and you'll
probably see the little clip with Rumble
where it's like hey and then three or
four people die in about a second it's
kind of insane yeah it's crazy
Abby speaking of two taps we'll get
there in a minute but the March update
yeah they're just cool videos I always
appreciate like the editors and the
production value a bunch of videos or a
solid oh yeah
hats off to those guys uh so you'll see
all these now there are other this is a
big section right here and it'll kind of
come up in a little later so if those
videos you're asking for juicy details
yet it's like we've already got a lot of
feedback about this update and continue
to monitor the conversation we
this hasn't addressed all of the
concerns brought up by the community so
they're aware hopefully and there are
other hot topics we haven't discussed
like random roles it's actually sounds
like it might be on the table don't know
but if it like if it's on this you know
bungees at least had a discussion about
it right so if they're actually gonna
put it in here because these things are
curated like crazy weapons Lots
progression system so our team has been
exploring each of these concerns behind
the scenes you'll see them front and
center discussing their solutions in due
time it was another step and that's what
you see it's a step in the direction of
our mission to improve destiny - and I
think that's fair and that's what like
I've tried to say it before the stuff
that we want them to fix cannot be done
quickly there's got a fair amount of
testing involved there's things like
that
I mean time-to-kill is one of those that
people argue you could probably do it
quicker and that might be one they could
I mean they could take the little bus
they did for 15 percent across the board
and PVE they could have just done that
like just crank everything up 20 percent
in PvE in PvP and just see what happens
and be like hey we're gonna do a test
this weekend and that's kind of one of
the things I wish they could do I don't
know how hard it is if they can do
archetypes which they so steam to do
archetypes as opposed to single guns so
just take a we're gonna crank up the
damage on every weapon in PvP by 20% for
a weekend just to see how it feels right
I mean I think that'd be kind of a way
for them not to do a public test server
but just to see be like hey you guys
want to see things to be more powerful
the things are kind of feeling pretty
reasonable I mean they're getting closer
but just crank it all up and like raise
that time to kill quicker and just see
what happens I mean I'm not saying it's
an easy thing to do and I'm sure there
are testers literally doing stuff like
that occasionally be like alright what
do you guys want to test today
crank everything up see what happens
sure like and I'm sure some of it is
complete chaos Rumble is already chaos
so you let that one go out and just to
see what happens but I mean random roll
and that's one of those that you could
do on a test server random weapon slots
progression systems that stuff just
takes development time I don't think
there's any other way around that
mm-hmm so I mean the mods they're
working on but random roles and weapon
slots those are huge and will kind of
cover that a bit later so hold that
thought guys we will come back to it
believe me we've had our fair share
discussions hang off of you about those
oh yeah so - Ringo unchanged yeah so
with 1.14 out the door their focus is on
1.2 that is the season 3 that may update
the expansion - all of that stuff you
want to call it so they talked about
strum and during because they mention
the exotic weapon tuning that they're
working on so that is a combination of
like sidearm and hand cannon and those
two that pair together and they're part
of that quest that you guys probably all
did now you have the gun sitting in your
vault not using them I did it I did
everything on ps4 and then when it got
to PC I kind of went for the stuff that
like mattered yes so I didn't have to go
back but at some point it well but
they're basically just saying for those
who don't know the core loop of strung
and drain kills with one weapon reload
the other while it stowed consecutive
kills with during will overload arounds
into Sturm so I'm sorry I'm saying that
wrong it's term capping out a 20 mag
round for a hand cannon that's actually
kind of cool it's easier sign-on for a
little while you're like okay I got a
couple ads coming up to me I'm gonna
kill a couple then gonna turn around put
some damage in ooh heavy I got 20
bullets and a hand cannon I'm gonna it's
gonna be awhile before I run out of that
mm-hmm currently the gameplay is focused
on fast swapping and while fun it lacks
the exotic flare we're hoping to add
Sturm is also a bit unwieldy
so we're addressing that too so they
said as a standalone weapon both strum
sturm sorry I don't want say strong it
just reads easier Sturm and Drang have
had their base that's improved for ease
of gameplay dragon now has rampage and a
maxed out magazine to help rack up
sidearm kills quickly the true payoff
comes in the overload Sturm magazine
over the phones in the Sturm now have a
damage boost of 1.8 at now that is HUGE
on the hand cannon because the hand
cannons typically are a three to four
if you're doing almost 2x and this is
literally where the next line comes in
significant damage increase in PVE and
crispy precision to taps in pvp so they
have a well-orchestrated video down here
I'm not gonna play it but you guys will
actually see them there takes that
sidearm gets a couple quick kills turns
around literally torn you can barely
react faster than he gets you so beast
it's kind of impressive now it's like
these two pair together and I kind of
like I mean if they do a damage boost of
1.8 X that solid now it takes a lot of
things happening correctly using your
sidearm adding our extract so these are
kind of use them together but I like I
mean I think I like this I think I feel
that these are you know kind of a way to
take a gun that may not have that much
to it you know you know make him a
little more viable no no but you know
they put one perk on Drang and they've
made it a little easier to use with more
ammo you still take exotic and it's kind
of like it's but it spares more with
Stern but again you're I don't know it's
like some of its good I like how they're
kind of getting a little more creative
with it but we're just kind of going a
little deeper and but I think some of
the I think the weapons of themselves
may just need a boost and just power yes
and I think that's what I go for I think
you know just jump in I think this next
update remember that if you look at the
roadmap it was about exotic rework and
they're making it was about their
narrative is saying making those things
feel powerful again making them feel
truly exotic so because we have a
plethora of legendaries right now that
are really beast and to be honest I am
going to it's a struggle for me to say
okay which is that am I really gonna use
I'm not really you're not used better
Devils am I really not gonna use you
know master works and it's just you know
right now exotics are in this weird
place is it they're not really that
dominant even in in almost you know I
can find a viable substitute so this to
me when I see this you know what does it
does I'm mispronouncing myself Sturm
Sturm and Drang you know when I see that
kind of stuff that means they're
thinking theoretically how do we really
maximize these exotics and I think I
think they're gonna go for
I think they really have something going
up the only thing I want to see though
not chest weapons
I've always been screaming this from d1
I want to see our more exotic armors
reworked me our fantasy or of whatever
it is like I want this there's too many
ineffective exotic armor pieces that
need significant boosts that I don't
want to see and that's always been
bungees Achilles heel they really don't
do that with armor they're they're so
focused on weapons so it's gonna be key
to see how that goes
yeah and that's literally what I was
gonna get to you stole the words out of
my mouth so no but seriously that's
exciting to say I was like aren't
weapons I think overall the idea behind
the exotic weapons some of them have a
pretty unique feel some more than others
I mean a five-shot pulls fire pool for
vigilance wing is gonna be tearing up
the meta for a little while but is it
that different not really but I mean
weapons you can probably only get so
creative per say the armor as you said
that's the point where some of those I
need you to just rip away that exotic
perk and build something new some of
them like built from the ground up so
yeah yeah that's that's where I'm hoping
to because I think the armor is where
you can change play styles yes of how
you want to play with that play style
absolutely and we've heard some good
things about what is right yes beasts in
they stalking about graviton Lance gonna
be beast in there doing more the
explosion I talking about all the fun
that they're having and it's play test I
want to hear about the fun that you have
in with these exotics armors we haven't
seen one piece of armor mentioned yet
and that's why I'm like because their
history has always shown they do not
revamp exotic armor and that's a problem
they have to do it you have to go out I
mean those are those pieces where you
want to make a tough decision because
yes you're gonna throw exotics at us and
I have 14a on Swift's make em work well
mm-hmm like all that stuff you've been
throwing at us for a while
so yeah but and that's why I'm literally
sitting here reading this I'm dropping
up for another to use of the exotic
weapon tuning and that's I want to pull
up the roadmap real quick so you guys
can see it
it says exotic weapons slash armored
sandbox changes so say I just I just got
a hope the armors on the other side of
it because it's in there
I just want to hope that it's yeah it's
quietly in the work so at some point
somebody's going to give us a giant info
dump on the armor all at once thankfully
and we figure and also let's be honest
like with this update you know every
expansion we're gonna get some new
exotics right we're gonna get so these
things gotta be able to compete the
oldest none has to be able to compete it
has to still be viable so I really want
them to dig deep with that I hope that
you know they don't let us down in that
regard with that absolutely we've also
got some changes to the companion for
those of you who still use it basically
you can render your guardian as you can
see so your armor if you just want to
look at and be like hey look at my guy
if you're still using your cell phone
yeah it's it's nice I mean you can
change shaders these to see some of that
stuff they've also got and I think this
one's actually kind of cool coming soon
they've been working on creating fire
teams for your clan in just the app I
mean invites to Sony and xbox straight
from the app you can make like scheduled
events and like times and stuff in there
I think they're making it just a little
more user friendly because not everybody
got you know destiny item manager or
another app some people are just like
hey I'm in the bunch of universe this is
my stuff like not everybody goes to
venture outside of the box to go reread
a threads and go to the lfg and do all
that stuff so if or your typical casual
user base which quite a few of them are
that's what they went for if you're
making it easier for them to just do
basic things from something Bungie
related that's cool totally fine with
that and that's good stuff mm-hmm
so quick topic of discussion the
affection rallies they have ended for a
little while they will come back in
season 3 hopefully a little more
revamped and they know but in case you
guys hadn't heard a new monarchy one
again oh it's good bad it's good I
thought it was
no way in hell they would with this wood
launcher versus two snipers but those
like that being said I let her just
looking up and it's kind of one of those
I wasn't thinking about as much because
I kind of gave up on caring about
cosmetics but as I guess that's most of
what people care about right now
it won't lock the ornaments on new
monarch or the prettiest so that's
literally all they were going for the
weapons from what I was reading yeah
they didn't hear and that was like some
of the comments on my videos on my
channel and stuff they're like I stopped
caring about the weapons I just thought
I wanted my ornaments and the shaders
and that was lit that's literally what
it is but what does that goal to tell
you see this this is where you down
leading into my point all point my point
which is early which is Destiny's the
bigelow of Destiny let's keep it real
part of the bigger law is besides the
loop this is a fashion show man you want
to look good you want to have that
unique looking stuff that looks cool
that's why I'm so hard on the knife fall
stuff right because the knife or
specifically was because there's nothing
that really looks so cool and there's no
armor right yeah people showcasing me
that Bungie is missing the point with
their game people love when you grind
for something that looks ornate that
looks cool that looks majestic you come
and you look really you know regal like
that's what new marquees doing that's
why new marquees winning it is the
coolest looking design that the shaders
it's a it's an amazing rework from how
they were from d1 d1 they were planned
right remember yeah dead orbit was the
way even you know you can taste the
rainbow Widow future Walker would you
skittles stuff but it was nice it's true
though they were pretty colorful yeah
they were all way so now that marquees
looking like this real legal amazing
looking faction it's gonna be hard you
know for the other things that are gonna
have to step up the game for the other
two all right so give me 30 seconds and
give me an idea for armor or ornaments
or whatever for dead orbit and future
work oh I've got an idea so on here
you want me to go first or do you want
first you go first so dead orbit
literally go with the name I want some
like skull and bones like almost a
necromancer look you be something looks
like that make it you like if I'm be
like if I'm gonna wrap dead orbit I'm
gonna look like death warmed over like
skeletons some bones necromancer some
darker stuff whatever it is actually may
be a little dark I don't know if that
jumps into the M category you got a they
should probably be able to bounce that
one out on the other side future will
call go Tron I don't like I mean a
little crazy goat I mean that razor girl
oh that's a different complete Anna but
but I mean they get to the go future I
mean think about Blade Runner think
about Tron think about all of that like
the bright neons the dark look like have
a nice kind of contrast between those
two have the crazy graffiti signs that
you see in Blade are all that stuff go a
little farther like if you're gonna make
new monarchy the Regal knights of the
round table now stacked to the iron
Lords podcast
take the other two farther out as well I
mean you've got a crest with like a lion
and shiny gold on and home in dead orbit
you've got black with a white brush
stroke on it I'm not trying to downplay
the artist but I feel like that one was
probably easier to create so again what
if it was like dead orbit literally had
like a what if it had a almost a fallen
captain's skull like on your Titan
shoulder oh stuff I mean like take it to
that level mm-hmm and I think that's and
that takes a lot of artwork time I'm not
a designer I don't know how long that
would take to render again it's not not
gonna even try and fathom that one
because my creative juices sometimes run
pretty thin but in general that's I
think the level people would love to see
yeah so hopefully when they bring them
back hopefully they do revamp them a
little more but also just making the
faction really something more people
want to be a part of apps if I just like
hey I'm gonna pick affection and I hope
it wins and not worry about playing and
going for the tokens where that's a
different problem
ya know I mean it's it's a cool little
feature they get it has so much
potential as a foundation so they really
have to expand upon it it really have to
make
Efrain have to make it mean something
and like you said they need reworks you
know hey come down you gotta hire some
otters hi some more artists you know how
about what those are faction random
ornaments how about what those um
Knights for specific rewards like
contract or something I mean be like I
bet you there are some people out there
who are aware of deaths are aware of
destiny who are also like three years if
they got a little time on their hands
like a little extra like and that's how
you really I mean you want player
engagement you got to give them a reason
and we'll kind of get to that a bit
later too if you want the fancy Bungie
bounty emblem as below listed so April
fourth 10 a.m. to 12 p.m. actually we'll
be home just before I go to work so I'm
going to try and jump in on PC just to
see if I can dabble in it is PC it's a
short playlist so I might have a chance
to see but unfortunately I'm playing
against the guys who live the game so
get a hope your random group of mayhem
which is already kind of crazy in the
first place will give you a chance to
play himself I don't know if you want to
jump in Bungie Banias there go for your
emblem so it's pretty cool to play
against those guys for sure I'm not
actually kind of decent yeah not bad
like it yeah it's clean but definitely
will stand out to be like okay you got
this one alpha dogs for your uh
nightfall top scores so this is when you
know things are fairly broken three
hundred seventy-five thousand four
hundred thousand your next one of those
two are actually relatively close in
twenty five thousand your number one
above that is seventy three thousand
higher than number two so if you're
talking you're a mole almost what 15%
higher than your second place score
that's set that's so broken yeah they
know it they're aware of it they're just
like AC you can do the most with it but
they have been saying only the top 1% of
breaking 100,000 each week so most of
the community put community is actually
putting up scores expected within their
thresholds when I see people saying hey
I got 60 hey I got 70 I was watching
Destin last night actually doing the
nightfall Ian CJ I think we're playing
and I don't know who the other guy was
but they were getting somewhere in the
62s as
a prestige they didn't crank the
difficulty all the way up but they were
working on trying to get up to that work
the you know 60 70 80 range and I think
that's so they said they'll continue to
track these scores and evaluate if we
through change up the thresholds for
earning emblems I hope it doesn't mean
literally change up hopefully it just
means change not increase because you
make them harder to get to then you're
gonna probably less people get there
which problem I mean for an emblem I'm
kind of okay if it was you had to get a
hundred thousand or something to get the
knight faulty reward and it was a badass
reward then it'd be like okay we're
putting I'm gonna grab my good friends
I'm gonna drag him back in here mmm-hmm
oh yeah I think they seem to actually be
in a reasonable spot from what I've seen
you know I'm kind of okay with what they
did so far apparently there is a bat
flying around in their servers they have
bad errors animals with the arrows they
funny yeah I mean it's like as a coder
you've got it I mean it's one of those
like whatever pops up it's gonna say
something it's probably just very easy
to see me like what are you gonna
monkeys bat like cheetah if you see any
of those things and you have to report a
book it's probably something to be like
all right got a cheetah over here it's
easy for them to hopefully dive back
into the code and be like okay it's
right here so it's uh I mean you know
everybody's got their way to do it but I
appreciate little animal references yes
sir
movie of the week pretty cool also
impressive a two man two plate one phase
Calais kill that was crazy I watched
that one didn't take him long but yeah
there's probably so many runs up into
that did not work correctly because they
almost have to guess or basically hit
all of the Saiyans in the in the throne
room just to get each like wave done so
no those guys were there warping like
crazy so pretty cool stuff
yeah finally this isn't this isn't even
our final form they have not evolved
into Super Saiyan 3 yet I'm just kidding
we have more changes coming to destiny
to this was another step and I think
that's the best way to phrase it yeah
it's a step that the next ones coming in
may that'll be a bigger one keep
I on our road map to see what's coming
bro you know hopefully nothing else gets
pushed off off of that one into fall we
all get weird - no mods are out there so
that's gonna be a big one for the fall
but hopefully everything else is out
there but that's pretty much it for this
week at Bungie a little more to talk
about
yeah so there's two places we've seen
this and this is kind of this is between
Paul Tassie's article if you guys may
have seen this recent one it mentions I
love this advertisement on the left of
my screen that's cute
eleven of bungees twelve known issues
with destiny - a problems destiny didn't
have so that was politics he talking
about it and then I think this was
pulled directly from Kosmos response to
this basically just the community listen
if you guys are wondering if they're
like listening to what's out there but
things can't get done as fast as we hope
I think this is true no the last one on
vault space I don't know it's been three
years but that one aside but but now I
mean seriously it's and that's what the
vault space one I would love to sit down
with like whatever the database guy is
and be like alright just out of sheer
curiosity I just love to know I'd like I
want to understand it's like is it the
way the systems are developed is it like
a limitation here is it what renders
when you pull up a vault does it like
break your system does it try and load
all 200 things like - literally like I'd
love to know a game system curiosity -
yeah I don't think they would just try
and not give it to us yeah we know it's
got to be something yeah so it's like
mine's more just a curiosity at this
point just to understand but that aside
I've been talking for a little while so
I'm gonna grab a sip of water I'm gonna
let you kick us off on these uh
basically all these points that cosmos
like these are these are all on our
whiteboard somewhere these are these are
on the lists
yeah um shout out to my man demon Karasu
for my clan so we just got into it you
know this weekend he was aqua destiny
gala cos and um
you know we were just talking about the
state of things and you know what would
it take to get everybody in full force
and I was telling I'm like look ma'am
you know it's it's the weapon slot you
know a lot of you know shout out to doc
amnesiacokcomputer why dl was thriving
that's when people were having fun and i
was like dude that's the majority they
want that badly you know I mean people
want to use their how they used to have
their LD ARS and a thousand yard stairs
you know in that second slot so you got
that up in there boom I agree has to
happen
then we got random roles the main
problem with destiny too as it stands is
yeah unfortunately I got AB role my man
Luke Smith up you know he's saying I
know you know when you get your fourth
better Devils I was gonna be different
there's no difference this is one of the
worse things with destiny that when you
get a duplicate it has no value that is
demoralizing like when you get something
that's the same thing over and over you
it just D values what you know what it
have at least with d1 you had that
chance of it coming with head seeker you
had it you know one of those cool perks
that would separate it from you know out
of its archetype a little bit and you
were really grinding you're like man I
got this sick roll yeah I mean all this
gun so it's just like that has to be
addressed
that's a huge part of a loop based game
having that uniqueness having it be your
own you know we shout out the doc you
talked about your hyung
during all that stuff making the that
was it the druid was it the duplicate
drops me was the third one believe um
you know listen they gotta make drops
meaningful at all you know long the time
to kill that's a big one you know a lot
of people are really going in on that
right now you know um you know we
destroyed the whole you know the strike
rewards' you know so that I don't cover
that yeah you know we destroyed that you
know secrets all secrets there's no real
secrets in this game and you know I mean
they went through be it see but I mean I
don't think wrath of the Machine art not
wrath machine rise of iron he had less
but they were still there be ghosts to
find out in the world so you actually
explore these cool worlds and look in
every nook and cranny and be like hey we
had the lore to go for in the number and
then all the stuff with the Dreadnought
pieces he had to find I mean some of
those little chests hunt understanding
the puzzle had to go get this debuff to
run across here jump across these
invisible puzzles so at different people
could stand on it so I could get it like
that stuff hasn't been there
so I mean shout out to making the
dread-nots but we need that for D to
yeah badly like we need it but there's
no mystery I remember people you know
we're trying to figure out that steeper
stimulant question the codes what does
it mean and you know I'm saying like
this so it just adds to it was so fun
and we've got a shout out there the
black spindle and I was one of the
greatest ones they did you know and just
making a daily thing
have a different twist you know don't
those are the things that you know
really invigorate the base and on top of
it those weapons were powerful that's
another problem with d2 that the stuff
that you do grind for it's really not
that powerful I think that sniper that
they're dropping with it what is it the
permittee and Shrike his nuts like did a
shout out to unknown play made a great
point about the videos like you want
this thing when you grind it this hard
for it the grind to get there the
randomness of it is very difficult it
better be damn power
oh do something that nothing else is
doing and it's like they just keep
missing the mark with that kind of stuff
so yeah you know you got that and the
collectibles the difficult activities I
agree exotics more powerful in their
defense that's supposed to be coming
next update yeah so you know I'm gonna
give them a pass with that one direct
access the specific activity that's huge
because like we talked about with
crucible if you just want to do one
thing right you know be able to do one
thing it's like to say I want to go play
the you know almighty mission say I want
to just literally go play that taken
strike even though I probably played it
too many times if I do strikes but I
just want to go play a strike to grind
it or I want to go do this thing like
this is just more player choice to go do
that I was like I understand sometimes
in PvP it could be the player base where
you have longer wait times and things
like that they don't want to have 50
play lists but in a PDP stuff it's
either you or a small fire team if I
just want my shoes what I want to go do
I don't know why we can't yep
why can't we do that one of the biggest
ones longer tail progression quest
activities reason to grind tracks that's
one of the biggest ones so that 11 ties
into five yeah because he again if you
know if you you can have 11 all you want
which is you no longer did the
progression but if the the the the carry
and the six sucks guess what nobody
ain't doing it cuz I'm gonna be on siree
boxes when I literally said alright I
don't want them to so I don't want to
spoil every night for specifically what
but I had to see how one looked right I
had to quench my curiosity and I'm
sitting there watching a no player's
video and I'm like this is it we can't
be serious and part of me is like I'm
not climbing for that I'm not doing it
you know what am I gonna do all these
things for and there's really no unique
weapon or armor gameplay benefit that's
it that that's it's so demoralized
that's how you get people to check out
of your game because
gonna say why am I going to put in it is
you know you know it's to another point
case in point Long Point coming up I
said that with a prestige the prestige
raid I said I am NOT doing when I saw
that the only difference was that the
tenth of the armor was a little
different and the the reward for Acuras
was a white shader I said I put my foot
down like no Bungie no you're not making
me do that prestige rate for this BS and
I think they've lost track because it's
just been oh now just throw a whole
bunch of tokens Adam right they they're
thinking reward means more of the same
no reward means unique refers to each
activity is something that should and
unique and powerful now granite legend
hackers was okay I'm not gonna say that
was a terrible thing
but they needed to expound on stuff like
that more of stuff like that you just
can't change the color of armor and
expect me to be like yo I'm gonna grind
out six of my God my God we're gonna do
this thing man we would that different
color like no the raids that gonna get
played that's how it's gonna go the
knife was not going to get played you
you keep giving people BS rewards with
no power it's not getting played sorry
long pissed at that like I really it
really disheartened me when I watched
his video and I got a sneak peek oh hey
ghosts
come on Sparrow no I suppose if there
was like a weapon armor and a cosmetic
for each and you had a hard trying to
get them all yeah I might not get him
all over week but when it comes back it
gives me a reason to keep going a
shout-out for my man Michael looking
want you to check he's like he's not
gonna grime for the same stuff that
that's people's point they look you get
it you that's gonna look that's gonna
see okay what is it you know shout
Macie he put one up you know and the
community I can hear it in their voices
like yeah it has these two perks and you
know okay and it didn't even look that
cool you know like it needs to look cool
it needs to be some fly ish in the game
make it a third Ripa's armor just
literally render that again a jump to
his other leg i said i'm saying he's
hold on his elbow you render that
minimize it in the gun form you get
people high
give me when you beat them you know a
part of the armour you get that helmet
yeah how cool with that have been mm-hmm
had this indie one they had this is when
you killed the dark blade remember yeah
head pops off you're like fallen saber i
got the thing
i got a cool machine gun you had you had
like that double tree and what i'm
hoping i'm really hope is that they are
continuing to add to the pool it's gotta
if they got to do that it gotta make
them unique and i don't know what you
what they can do if it's if it's the
live team like you're saying hello you
need to hire some more artists and it
did but yeah first of all hello y'all
better now be working on d3 major
expansion year to whatever that is oh
yeah I was like so I mean so questions
on a couple of these since we're pretty
much neck deep in it at this point as
well diving a little farther mm-hmm
weapon slot changes so there's probably
shout-out to chat by the way a couple
you guys Texas Flacco TF Chronos Zack
Zack attack all you guys thank you for
tuning in weapon slot changes there's
probably I think two major schools of
thought generally you've got the d1
build so you've got a primary a special
and a heavy mm-hmm
no the other one makes a little more
interesting for d2 I've heard for
primary energy or kinetic energy and
power as they have it but then you add a
fourth be a college special if you want
to write so what do you of those two
where would you like to see it go
this is tough the problem is like I said
they boxed himself in this corner with
drastically changing they did the weapon
slots right so now it comes down to do
they break their game so just be always
they break it but they have to make a
fundamental philosophy change and say
this has failed we're going back to you
know primary secondary heavy um
this is tough I don't necessarily think
it's an easy answer as most people think
most people just say hey put it back to
how it wasn't d1 you know I get that I
wouldn't be mad if they did I say that I
wouldn't be mad if they did it to me
it's just like me and you've talked that
nauseum offline which is the problem
right now is heavy right heavy in my
opinion is the problem and energy hat
doesn't have enough diversity right
energy seems to be replicating just what
primary's doing yeah so so that's where
the issue comes down to so okay yeah you
can just bring it back to the initial
thing I get it um the only thing I say
is if they if they're so if they do that
fine that's great everybody one guys are
happy
I guess case is closed if they're so
convinced though system wise that they
don't want to quote-unquote break their
game because you know what a lot of
these devs are very sensitive towards
that and they they kind of double down
with this new weapon system if they're
not gonna do that then you either a have
to do the four slot or be like we talked
about move snipers fusions grenade
launchers out of heavy and move that
into secondary if you're not gonna go
all the way with the b1 change yeah it's
gotta be one of the other because
they've got since they're the data guys
right they have to have the usage rates
right oh yeah do most of the power
weapons are probably not
next they're not used it's not used you
know I'm saying now granted I've been
playing this new matter I've been
getting killed by shotguns a little bit
more now you know I'm saying I don't see
Rockets as prevalent because of that
people we forgot to talk about a little
bit
they nerf rockets in terms of power and
crucible so now as far as at the amount
of ammo you can have you can only have
one as opposed to the two so they're
trying to make in their way a little bit
trying to make rockets not as viable you
know I'm saying but ultimately you still
gonna pick that over snack you're still
gonna pick that over the grenade
launcher that kind of thing because it's
one shot but it's the likely one
guaranteed kill as opposed to a sniper
you can miss you can body you can get
tagged shotgun you got to get up close
there's a risk or nades just a hard to
hit with or all of those pieces even if
it's two or one I mean - if you got one
off you half the time you might get
killed if you're in kind of a tough spot
up in the air so you might not get that
one so you're probably used to giving
one kill anyway especially if you ran
with something like were clip coil you
got one spray the dude whatever is in
front of you and that you know ten by
ten bucks in front of you it's gone but
that's it so I mean if it's one rocket
or something else do you still pick the
one that's probably on a map double kill
with a group yep absolutely so I don't
know from I think for me where yeah my
worry of just going back to d1
you take two weapon slots kinetic and
energy that are relatively all the same
type and you shove them into one so you
take all of the kinetic Scouts snipers
there are scouts auto rifles submachine
guns sidearms pulse rifles hand cannons
and then you have a duplicate column you
shove them all into one you have one
weapon type that has a lot of options
and you have the other ones that have so
few hmm
so what you want break it down you want
you know what I think
so they don't completely have to do away
with their current systems I like what
you're saying take power and split it up
take the snipers pull them out because a
sniper doesn't have the same feel I'm
even watching people still use it with
PvE in strikes I'm gonna shoot a rocket
at most things yep and it's probably
gonna explode and die
I can body shot are almost headshot
something in a nightfall cuz it's a
higher activity especially a prestige
and it won't die in one shot mm-hm
said this last night we gonna quote it
if it's in the power ammo [ __ ] so that's
a one-shot kill has to be there's no why
anything I think that should be a rule
it's a rule
I agree now so shotguns depending like
legend about race is kind of a beast but
Saudis are kind of a tough one their one
shot but their risk worse award right
but I think the risk of being that close
getting up in there being in the mess of
what potentially a team could be
probably still I feel for me just from
testing one probably more experienced
than that one I still don't think
shotguns have the same gravitas and
explosion and power that a rocket
launcher does so pull those up to a
special slot snipers the same way and
then the fusions I think I also agree
they're harder to hit you can one-shot
meltem but I still feel that special
slot what the bait change needs to
happen well there's two ones kind of an
ADD but I'll get to that in a second
her nade launchers should be for one
absolutely a one-shot in PvP
yes place has to be a must like whether
it's the explosion you got to bounce it
you'll have more ammo to counter for it
it's one of those that explodes on the
ground you gotta have a little more aim
so you might have you know one or two
less that's still more than a single
rocket but if you there's a grenade
launcher that explodes near you it's a
grenade launcher if there's an my house
I'm probably gonna be worried about
dying much less in the same room that
I'm in and this is bunch and this is
like you know God to your destiny
grenade launchers they should be
extremely powerful yes one-shot damage
preach man you preaching it like that's
exactly what I was dealing when I again
I was putting the matter to its paces
I'm sitting there dusting off all these
grenade launches thinking something
specials gonna happen and people are
just walking through the explosion blast
and smacking me in the face and killing
me like yeah back to the hole yeah I
mean and that's and I think you could
take the ghost you can move it down to
the bottom page if you need to adjust
that and I think that would be a way not
to break as much I'm just gonna break
things you can get more ammo to keep
track of things like that but I still
think that would be a way to keep most
of what they built you can still have
like a scout and a hand cannon but
honestly if you give the people more
variety and ways to play it's probably
gonna be a little more fun ammo may not
be as much of an issue which it already
is for a lot of things but if I'm like
hey there's a scout rifle there's a hand
cannon for clothes there's a sniper I
can dump into but if I'm out of the
Scout or the sniper I can potentially
use both interchangeably right and not
be like where's why am i running out of
ammo is watching deston play last night
and he's basically going through its
like hey I'm gonna kill I'm gonna wipe
for ammo that's bad I was like and
that's something that like in PvE ammo
is such an issue of sling I don't know
so the decision obviously made the the
conscious decision as far as like you
know getting rid of the ammo since yeah
and yeah I kind of I know I was like
that's another one would be one of my
heavy because but III give them a pass
for the only reason was because there
were times when you know you fighting
bosses and people like are gonna wait
for I'm interesting
respond of me their counters I guess a
little easier so I guess they figured
the way to combat it is just to remove
that aspect and then they're trying to
you know get make heavies give you the
reward it's tough man i I do understand
the logic behind that one I got to
defend them just to play devil's
advocate on that one a little bit what I
do see your point you shouldn't be in a
game also where you like them haven't
you know
can get much ammo you know what now
because stuffing I'm not that nice stuff
there to kill to get it so it's tough
stuff yeah so yeah I mean that would be
if I if somebody was like hey how would
you change it that's roughly how I would
that's my theory one other thing we
talked about we know random roles we
want them it'd be nice for more perks
would be nice for some better perks in
there just more variety and things like
that
duplicate drops meaningful that's when
they've got to figure out yeah I mean
that's just one word it's like if I have
a better devil's masterwork why do I
ever ever need to see another one across
my entire account exactly
so I mean unless now if I had a better
devil
say if you have a masterwork and you get
another regular mm-hmm say when you
break down the regular if it can check
that you've got a masterwork you've
already upgraded it break that down give
you one core mmm
just one master work or maybe help me
upgrade some other stuff maybe master
work words you could re-roll and that
may be a bigger thing later well if I
have just one that I've already upgraded
you know make some time to get some
Raynaud's but now you start getting some
duplicates of other things if you play a
lot I mean that's even a small piece and
I don't think that's like even a great
fix but something would you max out a
legendary ax to the level that it can
get no more and I get another one of
them helps me in no way just no way
possible yep so again it makes the loop
feel useless you have all that you just
you literally just sharding and it just
yeah they've got to do something I got I
want to know how to implement it I'm
worried that they might not go all-out
random world and they made my gut is
telling me they're gonna do something
like I like the mod slot is and make it
a perk cuz let's be honest they kind of
did that already with the when they when
they did was it update to when they
redid the raid armor stuff very specific
remember they just added an additional
slot in the your existing raid armor
once you did the raid then you can
change it when you do more solar damage
or anymore whatever my gut tells me that
they're gonna not fully commit I hope
I'm wrong that they we're not fully
commit to random rules and what they may
do is give an additional role slot in a
way that the mod is and then have a set
a bunch of perks that's kind of fixed
into that you know and it just better be
substantial it better be good it's got a
it's gotta be more than the master work
as far as because the master works are
cool for orb generation but let's just
be real like the actual the actual
weapon benefit oh you're real Oh speed
goes by it's so minimal you know I mean
now it doesn't really make it feel
different you know from anything else
and a lot of it just comes down to it I
think they're just scared to you know
break the meta and unfortunately people
want that people want that to feel
powerful and when it when they they want
the perfect combination of perks on a
gun
yeah something else to grind for using
the grind shoutouts I got to in chat so
first a question so do you think if
random roles come back will master work
stay um yeah I think I think they will I
think um again again this is just my
prediction I think they're gonna add
that mod slot I think that's the way
they're gonna handle random role but in
my opinion for them to do it right they
gotta have a whole bunch of different
perks and all part of the perk rotation
you know it's all piled just powerful
perks yeah and then shut so that was
Texas flacco asking that question then
Zack so he said more master work slots
one for each column so like say if you
had different columns of perks say there
was like you had a master work girl in
UK oh you got your first master work all
right well you want to put a little more
into this one have your second column
and then there's another set maybe the
master works can just be the random
roles as you're saying so yeah add a
couple extra layers to those and if you
want to be able to get you know you can
get rampage and then a boost to 10 range
and then maybe even a little more
packed like if you can get three more
pieces on a gun mm-hmm
when they only have like two perks in
the first place every minute like the
the perk section seems so shortened if
you give us two or three more columns to
really cut some of these guns be like I
want to go and then then say I want to
reroll that second one I want to keep
giving range and range and range on an
auto rifle so maybe this one now feels
like Uriel's probably did when it
started mm-hmm good point but that's the
difference say somebody else wants to
take a scout rifle high-impact go higher
and higher higher impact that thing
almost hits like a sniper rifle yes like
let us really dive into that
customization let us make some of these
guns our own with the stuff you've
already made Thanks because I remember
remember what it used to encourage
remember when you play d1 and someone
had a guard role weapon in the crucible
and you like mm-hmm
you like what am I gonna kill by what is
that I want I know ya lookin at the town
your skin you like oh okay
he's got des he's got it's got you know
this perk and it's got army of one and
it's guy you know say whatever it is it
just had these you know things you like
okay I gotta grind for that that's the
role to get you know I mean absolutely
you know you play there's nothing more
demoralizing than getting your fifth
better Devils it's the same thing that
was absolutely no difference so I guess
there's a question do you want random
roles or do you want masterwork
customization if you had to pick one
that would be interesting do you get a
random base and then still have the
chance to extend it and I mean you're
gonna be drivin forever if you get to
that point which I know that's Louie was
like how smart that chain to go he was
just indeed what we sustained in front
of Bochy all day remember my gunsmith
videos be like I am I gonna get my
hockey knee remember the name of the
sniper which oh I think I do
yes my IRA there are four always I have
one of my favorite roles on that gun
because I had triple tap on all Milan
which was already like one of the
highest hitting you could get I'm trying
to say pull up d1 right now sorry I
gotta look old it on come on come back
to me destiny Ida manager it's probably
equipped on one of mine honestly load
faster Irene are four I have triple tap
ingénieur
increased ability and faster handling
giving up range I don't care about range
on sniper rifles so perfect and Mulligan
so this was my perfect killer so I got
four shots out of one that hit like just
a boss and then on top of that if I miss
one I still get that bonus for the
triple tap I just unload all day long
mm-hmm I was your baby it was special
right and that was me and not
everybody's but that was mine and and
was dope about random roles is that
because it's so hard to get like you you
you got that attachment it was yours you
know other people's are different you
just had a whole different experience I
remember I would have five versions of
the same gun in my vault and I was okay
i'ma break these down which one feel
better yours and you sit there you're
tweaking a minute
that's part of the endgame that's part
of that grind that we want that that we
want that minutiae right we want that
you look at my hung jury scout rifle
with triple tap anyone in the magazine
for you circles I was like sadly that's
not even that many more perks maybe one
more tier but they mattered more the
perks were bigger so so yeah shout out
and chat they're saying like uh it's
like they miss hung jury they played
destiny one last night it's so much fun
it's like when Destiny's older Destiny's
two older brothers where people want to
go back to it was like yeah it's it's a
rough time my crunchy say
like addressing one all he think about
all that time he put in the trying to
get a grasp on my luck never remember
people remember people just grinding it
cuz it was a night fall and the chances
were better and you could get the rope
that's what it was about with him we
broke her - they would do like a tether
to field building guns and drop her
before it was but I was also like solar
burn and then probably solar burn paired
with I don't know if there's anything
else adding to that be a solar burn
celestial the six shot man that's B's
yep absolutely
so it has been a long point but I talked
about it last night there was one other
thing I wanted to bring up you feel like
I've got another topic here we go go for
it hey we got chat talk and I got 10
viewers over here so thank you guys so
much appreciate it shout outs to
everybody listening in for our wonderful
ramblings but when it talks about
reasons to grind and it talks about more
weapons and armours unique rewards where
they talked about the strike specific
loot and what we would like to see was
like as kind of what I mentioned you
last night and I kind of want to get a
feel for chats we've actually got kind
of an active one going shout out to
check so absolutely shout out to chat
thank you guys always the support is all
for all for you guys thank you we were
talking about armor last night and I
kind of got into the whole coming from a
Diablo coming from a world of warcraft
gaming background for a lot of RPG depth
and most things in our P G's in general
typically start to get into sets you
will have set bonuses now we have a raid
set now the rate actually has some perks
on it that one's gonna be a little
different so but you have sets of armor
at almost everywhere else outside of the
raid that have no benefit besides
cosmetics so I know I want the weapons
stats
looked at interviewed I even tweeted
straight at Cosmo this morning just ask
and be like what are the thoughts on you
know increasing speed having
the resilience be like I want to feel a
little more tanky if I go ten resilience
like I want to feel like I can take that
extra shot or two that snipe from the
boss I may be a little slower but
because I'm slower I can take that shot
on a prestige nightfall from Dracula and
it won't kill me because I have more
health those I definitely want looked at
but that's not what I've been talking
about when it comes to the set for
European dead zone or the crucible or
Cevallos nightfall set you have a set of
armor from each of those guys if you
want another reason of something to
grind a longer tail progression as
they're talking about mm-hmm I would
love to see a European
tightens a good one because I know the
enemy type they're pretty specifically
we're take a Titan set from Sloan she's
got a it's got you know kind of theme
for whatever Titan is maybe some of it
looks like the archeology you've got
some water looks on it maybe some kind
of wavy look but you've got a set bonus
say you wear two pieces of that set and
you get a 10% bonus to hive what is all
over Titan hive they're everywhere in
savathun song so if I'm gonna go work on
the nightfall I might grind a little
more for that Titan set so I can have a
little bit of bonus damage towards tight
towards hive enemies and be more
successful because I've grinded more
right and then say it's like if you get
a full set of five maybe it's like 20
percent and you get another I don't know
just something like I would love to see
weapon stats when you wear certain
pieces and give us a reason to look
different like you don't shade it
however you want but give us a reason to
wear different sets right though and
give us perks from doing that tracks
I nailed it right on there man don't bet
isn't it that's just I haven't played in
so many games that have had full sets
like if you're gonna do this crazy thing
in World of Warcraft there was an arena
if you're gonna wear the full arena set
you get a bonus that helps you a lot in
there it gives you general benefits but
it has something that you can be layered
tailored this way it's gonna help me a
little more here if I'm gonna go grind
on a flash point give me a reason to go
do it how am I gonna get the armor maybe
you could get some of the armor from
lost sectors
right good.you man I didn't know it
stack the specific loot and again I'm an
armor and stuff it's just this is what
we want man this is this is the kind of
stuff that people love to grind for and
it's significant and it's like and
honestly right now I wouldn't ask for
anything crazy per se like if you're in
season 3 and you could put it in there
just for the sake of trying it yeah I
would say take like whatever armor set
you had sitting in there and you could
literally reskin it for all I care I
don't 3 wipe the slate clean so nobody's
like hey my season 2 okay this is gonna
be new for three we'll just make color I
don't care about that okay set bonuses
test out perks add a little bubble in
there that'd be like added it's a static
one for your tight and set and it
activates when wearing - oh it's like
now do I know is that easy to program in
no but that would be a way with the
assets that they've got - not trying to
have to rebuild a completely new armor
set I mean that's like you know I'm
gonna have a Titan set in year two maybe
I want that a little more a little
cooler looking but right now just to see
how it goes
that would be awesome cuz you'd have a
power level increase you'd have those
sets that you could go grind for on
different worlds max and like and if I'm
gonna go run high of all day if I'm
gonna like if it's a nightfall strike on
Sabbath oon song I'm gonna want that
full nightfall set to be more successful
get a higher Sally it's like they
complement each other than that I think
yeah go ahead
no I'm just gonna jump in with this I'm
glad that you're on it's the armor set
tangent because that's something that
they've you know weakness of theirs from
d1 that's something I've always wanted
you want that full set bones because if
the exotics are gonna be that good right
yeah which we want you know we still
want to have some benefit if you wear
you know an entire set of a legendary
night you know what from whatever source
you may have got it from you know you do
you do want that kind of bear and I
noticed this go around right the at
least in d1 the armors
Alma's did have at least some perks to
it you know I mean that like it just
seems for the most part like outside of
the you know the mobility recovery
resilience that there's really no
differentiator between the armors yeah I
mean like the the raid perks were the
first step the exact they but they've
got it on one set in the whole game even
if so take it just a raid perk and slap
I mean even if you don't to change it
that much just use the way the same way
you implemented a raid perk put that one
in there but say you know do a check if
you're wearing this piece and this piece
you're good to go
and maybe you have a chance another slot
outside I mean that'd be it may take
away from the raid set or whatever but
you can you can add on to all of that
stuff and I think I'm not saying any of
its easy not a programmer I have no clue
so please remember this is all in giant
question of I don't know how the
programming works I'm that developer but
using assets that are there systems that
are there most of it I think is there
could give you a lot more reason to kind
of grind for it yeah if you put that
system in place I mean it's way too soon
probably to put that in May but if
somehow that was in there or even they
put it in and they had these type of
things before fall came out then you
would have people like okay like there's
there's reasons for things so absolutely
and then finally if somebody else was
just saying grim or I miss my grandma oh
I knew miss it I mean it's to the point
now it's like whenever we do these last
20 long points is that you know it's
literally all they had to do with carbon
copied evil make a few tweaks you know
that these massive reinvent the world
the wheel tweaks it's just it's it's
very interesting
like I said when it comes out maybe in
Jason trirage book part two we'll get
the real story on the failings of this
they do and what happened what was the
thought process of you know these
decisions that will copy me yeah there's
like and that's it's kind of one of
those that's like
it's okay to try and change some things
like I mean if they had had the three
weapon slots and they're like hey we're
gonna give you another option a fourth
if they put a three in right or if they
put a fourth slot in from the start and
we're like hey we're gonna give you
another slot so you can use to everybody
wouldn't like alright this weird but I'm
kind of alright but when you take away
that was I mean they they took too much
away from d1 and it didn't give us
enough back into d2 right like if you
take away the crucible playlist mm-hmm
us another an alternative to custom
games or something you take away the
grimoire the lore the ghosts and there's
no like secret quests or anything out
there like everything is so just here's
what you can do these are your 4 like
exotic quests you can do three missions
a week and you have regular strikes with
no modifiers like I don't know sometimes
that's it yeah yeah ball drop you know
again Waldrop the decision makings we
just don't know what like you say you oh
we you say it constantly every every
fight I promise yeah I probably do too
much but yeah I know where you're going
so I love it cuz you say all I want to
know is what's the thought process what
led you to that decision
why that's all I want to know music and
they be interesting when the book comes
out when the movie drop we gonna find
them do the creation in the documentary
exactly the fears it's ten years in the
making
how do you repeat history how do you
fall back on your face after sate ah so
it's so much do it yep so yeah if you
guys I mean the fact that Bungie is has
a list like this means that they're
aware do they know how to fix it I don't
know do they have ideas probably like
20,000 of them every everybody and
there's probably like okay we got a
whole pissed off community a lot of
people are leaving our games we have a
lot more competition in tattoos coming
Red Dead Division read dead 2 is coming
so much is like bearing down on them yes
like they
they have to have ideas for all of this
stuff the time it takes implement the
time it takes to get through dev cycles
artists to create these things like I
mean all that stuff takes time it's just
the question of when will things be
where everybody wants it back to be when
is it going to be the game that really
like hooks you in and is it fall is it
d3 yeah well III because even if there's
small trickle changes of all the things
we want to do right I don't know even if
over the course of like fall if they can
get enough in there so it's a the time
these small things and gets all stuck
all right direction then you have to
like relaunch all over again right
hopefully bring it the last six years
you know like I said I mean you're right
and the question is it like we've always
talked about it is it enough time is it
are we just hoping when realistically is
so much damage that may have been done
and it just can't do it but the only
reason why you hold out a sliver of hope
is because we have seen them have I
taken King moment we have seen them rise
from the ashes and we reinvent the wheel
you know member when they did light
level they they did a lot of changes in
taking King fundamentally besides the
content itself being great they did a
lot of base changes and quality of life
stuff and it was really good in
conjunction with you know a great story
and you know good story and solid DLC so
it's amazing reign you know it's gotta
be that perfect storm of things
otherwise it's gonna be here wait till
d3 this is a wrap no one you know no
one's coming back and a competition is
too strong so anybody out there and Chet
if you want to chime in since I got more
in there today than usual I just want to
ask you guys as I've asked Cognito
before we have our thoughts what is the
timing for a taken King moment that you
feel is acceptable if it's big enough to
matter if that made sense it's a lot of
caveats on that question so take a cake
taking King moment we know we want it we
know we need to rebuild on lots of
things is it the fall that we kind of
all expected to be September my honest
ask and that's where there's the
Activision
of you have you basically do September
or you run into everything else in them
yeah no choice to hit it but then do you
feel it's enough time for them to get
the game or it needs to be for taken
King drop or do you go early 2019 if it
needs more time so I was like I know
what we want I know we'd love to have it
tomorrow but right realistically where
where do you guys see it just so feel
that one out in chat we've talked about
it before it just seems like as more and
more things keep getting pushed off and
they've got all this stuff on a table
now if this list right here on Kosmos
post is like a fall hopeful rewrite of a
game like so but again if 90% of a
thousand people are working on it maybe
they can swing it I don't know like I
don't know what they're I don't know
what their time is but I know this has
gone on for a while guys so it's like I
got one guy on the other side of this
who is probably getting a little tired
needs to crash yeah yeah so we we can
wrap this one up here but thank you guys
for tuning in awesome to get the
commentary going of course
chat was lit and shouted a chat
seriously on both end so which you got
iron Lords podcast thrown it up on the
other side yes sir
I don't I wish we could mesh those two
chats together
your chat see my chat just watch both
streams at once I know actually would
twitch just like pop out the chat window
so just do that no oh yeah guys leak
steps in the right direction all of this
stuff is I got to 2019 so far but
seriously um I think all of us know we
want this game to be great and we feel
it has its great moments when I'm
playing in the game nothing and
especially on PC the way this game runs
I know
hashtag ascension but it's hard to go
back to console it is but other place
you play it
we latest when you're playing a shooter
whether you're a console shooter or
Acey shooter the way destiny feels as a
shooter in either place is one of the
best absolutely no question I think
everyone agrees to that I knew once you
touch that you had a piece of the lavish
life I got a big rig now I kind of enjoy
it
listen I'm not mad at you I just gotta
get you to I will tell you dude if you
sat down and played it online that's why
I don't want to play I know what's gonna
happen I'm getting bougie and then you
come home to your console and you give
you a console I don't want that I know
me I'm this I when I have the best
version of something I've always been
that way I cannot go back the only thing
that's booked that trend has been like
to switch and it's because of
portability I can guess I got some
different animals into me different
expectations but just in general if
you're gonna play battlefield anywhere
I'm like I'm gonna do it where it's the
smoothest best-looking and you know I've
been mouse and keyboard long enough that
I can do it like even but even if you
play PC on controller has I know like
somebody like CJ and stuff like that
just the still way of feet it feels so
good but either way like the game we
know the bones of this game are great
like the way the guns feel they shoot
like the core mechanics everything is
great we just want everything we want
all the decorations around it it's got a
good foundation it's got a good frame
and the roof is probably there to
everything on the inside the furniture
the wallpaper the you know everything in
the kitchen like all those pieces are
what we want to be just what we hope for
so absolutely I mean hats off to Bungie
guys they take flak and they take it
well the community guys be at Dylan
Cosmo and each place no matter yeah
they're literally you said it perfect
they just take it left and right on the
chin and they just get back up for more
and they're great at it like for them to
always be positive to not call it out to
never have basically any salt on rare in
will lash back out when they literally
you know could
no crap they get every day to read it
yeah I jumped in there and I was like
ooh oh yeah you take a week off ready
it's like it's like I just left like you
know a whole bunch of Chinese food and
it like simmered in two straight salt
like facts so we are hoping for more
these are all great things to see when
this stuff comes hopefully in a way that
we all that is implemented in a way that
we enjoy it'll be a game it's just the
question is when and I guess we'll have
to wait and find out why and so it was a
long point guys we gave you a heads up
we are over two hours it's gonna be a
long render yep the stream is over two
hours so those of you guys who came in
and stuck with it huge thank you yes and
thanks for all the comments guys this is
exactly what we're going for be it you
know the questions you guys have if you
agree with just some of the thoughts
were saying and honestly I got a bet
if Bungie says they're listening to Moe
that most of this there's a lot of them
are probably yeah it's like we'd kind of
like to do some of this we're just we're
working on it like give us time it's
like things aren't done overnight so I
got a feeling many of these things are
probably enjoyed and/or not enjoyed but
agreed to by just about everyone
including budgie so they want this game
to be great just as we do there's no way
they don't they they're putting their
heart and soul into this thing all right
guys what you want to wrap up let them
know where you're at and then I will do
as well
another flashpoint in the books on the
lawn point in the books but it get fun
you've got a lot of things of my chest
this Sunday of course it is Church is in
session the iron Lords podcast on the
inner circle Network channel we will
have special guests stinger from nlg
it's gonna be a big show man
this guy's a veteran he's been a game
journalist for over 15 years in the game
we're trying to get him on the show for
a long time so we are gonna be going
down memory lane talking gaming and so
talking some retro gaming and also the
latest what's going on in these are
multi-platform gaming in the consoles
and stuff like that so please tune in
it's gonna be Sunday 1:00 p.m. Eastern
the Lord's Day the iron Lords will be in
the building so come check us out and of
course it's me Lord Cognito here you can
find me at Twitter
at Lord Cognito and I'm on Xbox Live is
the same cognitively 16 on ps4 switch
you actually switch I don't have to give
up my VIN number my social security
number anymore you can actually if you
follow me on Twitter at lorkhan you know
you can search for me through the
Twitter friend finder on switch how
about that and then for me as well you
guys know half you guys are watching not
half but definitely a good following
today on twitch so twitch.tv slash
Ubuntu so you can watch these live
either side iron Lords podcast or
twitch.tv slash e pontus Twitter as well
I usually try and keep you guys up with
news just my thoughts I'll be sending
questions out just always on they're
just kind of random postings as well
just just my shenanigans on Twitter yeah
and then finally on YouTube guys it's
where most of my content set be up my
guides and that Weekly resets my
opinions usually fall in there somewhere
like today I was going a or Tuesday it
was like okay mercury we've got no Cades
- this is like well there's a video that
doesn't exist but that's weird like why
were there none there's at least one so
random little tidbits drop in my videos
guys but my solo guides if you want to
just work through some stuff I'll help
you survive them that's what I'm here
for
I'll give you guys the detail the
knowledge and all that stuff to help you
guys get through all the wonderful
content oh yeah he bought us on there as
well so for all you guys out there thank
you hit those follows likes drop
comments subscribe leave us all of those
things thank you guys for everything so
find us out there
thank you wherever you guys are at
around the world Texas I think yours is
probably giving away Texas flag though
the reckons the rest you guys world when
I'd get afternoon good morning or good
evening thank you guys and have a great
one
peace